[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists do you have so much
stuff that you fantasized about renting
a giant dumpster and tossing everything
in it just so you can move on with your
life
well
we don't recommend the dumpster method
because there are better ways to sell
donate or recycle most things but it
sure would feel freeing wouldn't it to
start over with a clean slate that's
what we're talking about today on the
minimalist podcast what possessions are
you struggling to let go of
what items or rooms are weighing you
down
what would you feel like if you could
just let
go
then this thursday on the minimalist
private podcast ryan and i are going to
talk about letting go season we'll also
debate a dozen rules for simple living
from other minimalists are they helpful
harmful
or just a waste of time you can check
that out at patreon.com
the minimalist your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
advertisements suck now if you're
watching the video version of the
podcast right now you might notice
something a little bit different about
our setup today
josh behind you
oh my god oh my god he's finally doing
you in it's jordan the jedi
are you the first ever native american
jedi jordan
well now you'll notice something a bit
different here we're in a black box
space you're on the wide shot right now
danny jordan thank you for the theatrics
it was perfect yes he had a giant
lightsaber behind me if you're just
listening to the audio version of the
podcast which is fine but you'll notice
that we're in this new space and i want
to talk about that real quick because
today we're really talking about
starting over in various ways we all
would feel free from a clean slate what
do we have today behind us literally a
clean slate yeah
uh big thanks to a few people for making
this happen first off um we've been in
this new studio space for
almost a year now
and uh we just changed it after the
first year beulah
perfected the studio space yes
and uh then it was time for a change
yeah one of my favorite things is once
we've built something is to sort of uh
well tear it down
start over how can you tear something
down if you don't build it first
that's what i want to know that's right
no i think it's a good uh it's a good
lesson in
um i don't know like something adds
value one day and then the next day it
doesn't
and instead of clinging to it you can
kind of let it go i mean those paintings
were beautiful
um it looked really good uh it was it
looked like an art studio which was the
whole the whole purpose
um but yeah they it wasn't kind of doing
what we thought it would do so we had to
like let go of those paintings and
that's it wasn't easy like those are
great paintings those are gorgeous
paintings yeah um but yeah man here we
are we let it go here we stop clinging
that's exactly what i want to talk to
you about today is the the clinging
right uh before we do talk about that
though you bring up a great point ryan
is sometimes the vision you have in your
mind doesn't comport with reality so we
created this beautiful
art gallery
it didn't translate as well on camera
and so you and i sat down we were
talking about this and we realized like
oh wait a minute every time we go to a
tv set say we go to the today show or
good morning america or cbs this morning
it looks great on camera yeah but as
soon as you step back from the camera
you're like well wait a minute yeah
you're like how is this gonna look good
on tv right i've come across that so
many times yeah because it seems like
the lights are too bright and they're in
the wrong positions and then yeah you
just have like a little set
um and then yeah you see it on tv and
you're like oh
yeah that's the tv magic and so the
paintings it made this space really
beautiful to come work in and spend time
in it didn't translate as well on camera
in fact i bought one of the paintings
from beulah
about a month ago and
she's going to be selling the rest of
the paintings that were in this room as
well you can check that out at i think
we put it at the minimalists.com art and
that just forwards to her website
because i couldn't remember all of the
hyperlinks and so the minimalists.com
art if you want to check out any of
those paintings it's just uh well
they're there they're there your life is
complete without them but if you'd like
a little artwork on your walls then you
can definitely check that out but i want
to say thanks to biola for that first
iteration of the studio the other back
half of the studio here is still exactly
as she designed it we just put up a
studio tour over on patreon the fifth
and final installment of that studio
space before we blew everything up
studio tour season one yes yeah yeah
stay tuned for season two season two or
you know what is it uh yeah season two
season two has been confirmed
we've been renewed we've been ready yes
that's what the world was looking for in
alabama i want to thank you too because
she was sort of the project manager on
this space while we were gone
uh we were out on tour we finished up
tour and uh the american leg of the love
people use things tour we were in
chicago and minneapolis and we had oscar
come in here and do like three coats of
matte black no voc
paint
to make it look beautiful and now from
here with this clean slate we will
slowly iterate we'll make some changes
we'll add some backlighting
we'll add green screens and roller
coasters
wait a minute
no but we'll we'll slowly repopulate the
space to make it our aesthetic and what
i really like about this
is the fact that we we actually have
come full circle in a way jordan and i
were meeting here yesterday he goes this
is how we wanted the last studio space
to look on camera we just didn't have
the depth the space the equipment to
make that happen yeah we were in a
closet basically pretty much in our last
studio yeah and now we have the space to
make it beautiful so stay tuned to that
you can find it on our youtube channel
youtube.com
the minimalists or if you just want full
episodes of the podcast it's youtube.com
the minimalist podcast we have two
youtube channels because we're
minimalists that's right
i say we dive into some questions today
malabamba we got a question here from
peg on facebook
i am a neat freak and a minimalist but
my husband is not and drives me crazy
his nightstand dresser drawers and
bathroom sink are piled with rarely used
things to the point where i just want to
throw all of his stuff into a dumpster
help
hmm well don't throw your husband's
things into a dumpster that's theft
that's step one
wait a minute
oh man what it's funny because this is a
this is bothering peg
it's not bothering her husband
and it's often that we project our own
judgments and frustrations onto someone
else now i'm not saying
that there isn't some work that her
husband needs to do maybe there's a
you know maybe there's an unhealthy
situation if that's the case then yes
like you've gotta you've gotta approach
your husband about it but
dude the minute we come out with the
here's how you make your partner a
minimalist
we will be uh yeah we will sell three
million copies just like marie condo
[Laughter]
well i mean the thing about that is what
you're talking about is how do i get
this person to change their world view
right
and
what you're really saying is how do i
get them outside of their comfort zone
the comfort zone that we have is a
killer right and ryan is right that
these things aren't bothering him at
least consciously they may be bothering
him subconsciously sounds like your
husband is at least a
level one hoarder maybe even a level two
hoarder ryan and i even had some level
three hoarding tendencies back in our
consumerist days a level one hoarder you
know what a level one hoarder means you
have light clutter in more than one room
yeah
yeah no noticeable odors
yeah that those are like the the key
signs no noticeable odors uh-huh so
light clutter in every room yeah and
more than one room more than one room
and so clearly he's a level one horror
that's not a judgment right it's just
understanding that most of us
we tend to hoard we tend to cling and
you mentioned this earlier about the
desire to cling and and there are really
three reasons that we cling
to anything
the first reason is we want approval
from someone or validation or veneration
i need someone to look favorably on me
the other way that we look at that is we
mistake it for love i want to be loved
and this often goes back to childhood
trauma in our lives right and so instead
of pointing and saying oh my husband
needs to change these things let's talk
about why he may be clinging to some
things that aren't adding value to his
life
because you can tell him till you're
blue in the face you should do this you
should do that here are the benefits i'm
getting
but that's almost like talking to him
about
oh we're getting ready to go on tour in
canada we have two tour stops toronto
and vancouver coming up now imagine ryan
if we landed in vancouver
and i handed you a map of toronto
and said here you go
navigate the streets yeah right and
that's kind of what you're doing here is
you're handing him you'd be handing him
your map peg here's the benefits i get
but he may not experience those same
benefits he needs a map of vancouver not
of toronto what am i meaning there what
i mean is he needs to understand what
the benefits are for him that's why we
started our last film with that question
how might your life be better with less
not how
your life well and his life will both be
better with less
how will his
life be better with
less helping him understand that because
fundamentally
we cling to things for three reasons one
is approval i just talked about that we
feel like we have lost out on love
somewhere along the way two is control
this was my big one especially as a kid
because
my world was so chaotic and it's still a
big one for me right now uh it's it's
part of my program part of my childhood
trauma because the world was so chaotic
i clung to the few things that i had
because i needed that sense of control i
need to have control over something yeah
it's also the reason i over ate and i
was morbidly obese as a kid i could
control the calories i was putting in my
body i control the gustatory pleasure in
this moment and third and finally
safety or security that's why we cling
we think that i'm going to be safe if i
have all the right things the control
thing is fascinating because
we
the more we seek control the less the
more things get out of control because
you can control all these different
variables yeah and then you realize like
oh now i feel like i need more control i
witnessed this recently ryan i'm in the
process of moving right now because i
just bought a house and we'll talk about
that in a future episode we're going to
do a homeownership versus renting
episode in the future
but
i'm great with chaos outside the home
i'm able to function really well with
chaos everywhere but in the home
it is crippling for me yeah it's that
control thing man and it goes back to
that childhood trauma right yeah oh if
things are out of control i need to be
able to control something right but of
course if i get everything in order and
have all the right knick-knacks and all
the things in place and i have
everything under control
has it really changed anything has it
made me more complete
no the default setting in our lives
is enough
the problem is we're constantly seeking
enough
outside it's like trying to count to
infinity hmm
you can try to count to infinity
it's like trying to get enough yeah
infinity's already there you can't count
to it
enough is already there you can't get to
it and so if you're starting with that
state if
your husband peg if he understood that
he already has enough
then any of the things that he brings
into his life it's fine nothing wrong
with stuff peg you have some stuff in
fact you might even have some stuff he's
like i can't believe she has that thing
and that's okay
but we can bring those things in and we
can hold on to them as they're useful
without clinging to them long term yeah
so i'm thinking about reasons why we
cling so there's just in case stuff
which would be that would fall into the
category of
safety
and you know having something just in
case sentimentality does that go back to
the first one
so sentimentality is validation love
yeah i think that's part of i think it
depends on the person so we all every
human being has all three of those
approval mm-hmm we all need approval we
all need to control to some extent yeah
or we all need to feel safety right
yeah we think that we need these things
right and it manifests in different ways
even the hanza they need to have control
of their environment to make sure
they're not being eaten by a predator or
something right and safety etc in fact
safety tends to govern those other two
um when we when we really look at the
default there anyway
when i when i think about the just in
case item yes most of the time that is
well i feel as though
things are scarce
yeah and because things are scarce i
need to control scarce i don't have the
abundance mindset i have a scarcity
mindset right and so i need to cling to
these things to provide me safety or
another word for safety is what comfort
yeah and as we get bogged down in our
comfort zone now anyone listening to
this has probably had this experience
especially if you share our podcasts
with other people that's our most
popular way that we reach other people
certainly not through advertisements
obviously
people share it with their mother their
brother their sister or whomever now you
might have heard our podcast and you
dove deep and you listen to half a dozen
episodes and you're like oh my god these
guys they're onto something this whole
minimalism thing it makes a lot of sense
to me and then you share it with your
with your mom or your daughter or your
cousin and they're like yeah
that's fine i don't really see what you
see in there now why don't they see what
you saw is because you were willing to
make yourself uncomfortable
in the moment you're willing to get out
of that safety and expand that comfort
zone but most people are perfectly
content within their comfort zone and
you can't ask them to you can't drag
them out of their comfort zone that
creates suffering that they didn't ask
for right
but if they start to see the benefits
how might your life be better with less
how might your husband's life be better
with less because my guess is there's
some sort of childhood trauma or life
trauma in general that has caused him to
continue to cling and with that clinging
you get dragged and he's being dragged
in a direction now that might be
subconscious it may not be like oh i
realize i'm being dragged i need to let
go of this no it's just suffering yeah
and we hold on until we realize
that we can let go yeah
you know peg's question uh it's very
similar to some of the questions we have
today some of the questions we've got in
the past and really it's about
how to have a better relationship with
someone who doesn't have the same
thoughts about minimalism as you do
and you know i think that
and i know i was guilty of this having
this idea of finding like the perfect
partner
the soul mate someone who completes me
someone who
you know is just this this perfect
um perfect partner
but the problem is that there's no such
thing as perfect
there's no such thing as uh you know
someone completing you
so
you know when when i hear questions like
this
it's like yes i do wanna i do wanna make
an observation about how maybe you know
the situation can be approached a little
bit differently to help ease some
tensions or you know uh cut out a little
bit of anxiety or whatever it is
but really
you know what i want people to
understand is like
it's not a question of how can you make
this person fit into your life exactly
the way you want them to that is a poor
quality question you're never going to
get there so the real question is is how
can you work with someone towards
something that both of you can agree
upon
uh
that that path
that path is the that's that's in my
opinion that's the true path
yeah and what i'll say is that we
imperfect ourselves by trying to find
perfect external externally right yeah
it's like i'll just keep these things on
to me and they will make me perfect not
realizing like well i know i'm already
enough
and to me enough is a type of perfect in
a way and then those things there's
nothing wrong with playing the game if
you want to buy a thing because it's
going to make your life
easier you know having the app on your
phone with the the music or whatever
instead of buying cds like okay that
that makes a whole lot of sense for me
right but it doesn't make me better it
doesn't improve who i am inside and i
love what you're saying about the better
quality question there ryan because
instead of saying how do i get my
husband to understand that he's
suffering because you can't there's no
how to understand right you only set up
the environment for understanding that's
how we learn through immersion
and so the better question is why is he
clinging to these things and it goes
back to those three areas either he
feels like he doesn't have approval
maybe that's from you or from his
parents or from society
or he feels like he doesn't have control
and this is a way for him to regain
control at least theoretically of course
that never works it never gives us
actual control the the best way to get
control to gain control is to let go of
needing control yeah
and then finally if he feels unsafe i
doubt that's where he is so it's
probably one of the first two it's
either approval or
the need for control so get to the why
then you can help him better understand
not through a how-to but setting up the
environment for understanding let's move
on to our callers if you have a question
or comment for our podcast give us a
call
406-219-7839 or email a voice memo to
podcast at
theminimalists.com it looks like we have
a question here today from mara in
toronto
over the years i've received plaques
weird shaped glass awards with my name
on it big picture frames that you can't
really ever use because it says stuff
like rewards conference 2010.
it's kind of random things you get at
conferences and banquets although i'm
really happy to have the memories of the
award or whatever the situation was the
physical mementos have no meaning in my
life
and i can't think of how to repurpose
them and i can't stand thinking about
them sitting in a landfill forever if i
throw them away so i'm just curious what
you guys would do with them
what do you do with all your awards josh
all the awards i give you for best
friend
[Laughter]
runner up here's the uh here's the
plaque for runner-up best friend
you know it's fascinating because i have
two answers for this ryan one is what i
did with mine which was rather symbolic
and i wouldn't recommend that's why
we're calling this this episode the
dumpster method because it's not about
throwing things out if i could go back
and learn from my mistakes of
decluttering i threw too many things out
up front without trying to repurpose
them in a way that would be useful for
other people now symbolically it was
awesome
because i just literally took a trash
can and took i mean i had these heavy
really nice presents yeah man they were
like glass and like yeah a lot of weight
to them for sure you had the same ones
right yeah yeah man yeah yeah i uh yeah
i tossed mine because
hindsight i would have donated them
because i know there's like you know
some eclectic person out there that
would like because the awards were
beautiful
i mean you know they could have been
like an art piece you know or a weapon
they were heavy or a weapon yeah so i
know that like
you know they probably would have
eventually gotten tossed but at least
the opportunity like to be put out there
for someone to grab and you know some
hipster out there who's like oh i got
the number one present i have no idea
what this means but i have number one
presidents club award
and uh yeah i mean the landfill thing
the thing i always say
is
as soon as you purchase an item soon you
brought an item into your house it's
you've already done the damage to the
environment
so you know she says she doesn't
she can't picture the the awards sitting
there in a landfill forever
um but she also can't picture them
sitting on her shelf forever
and at least in the landfill they will
decompose a little faster than the
decomposition that will happen on your
shelf
um but yeah i say i say donate them man
that's what i if i could go back that's
what i would have done i would have
donated them in fact i've got some
instructions on how you can donate them
and so we'll get real practical on this
because i think this is a practical one
and you can learn from my mistake
because i don't regret what i did but if
i go back and change it i didn't regret
it for a while but i learned the lesson
as soon as you learn the lesson you let
go of the regrets yes right and so we
talked about that on our consumer
regrets episode
a few weeks back and there were two
things i wanted to note here ryan one is
i looked up like
artistic things you can do with your old
awards and trophies and i found this
pinterest board with like 141
ideas for your old trophies and they all
looked aesthetically horrible oh my god
they were awful they were hideous
there's 141 bad ideas on what to do with
your trophies people were using them as
coat hangers and like like you know what
for some people that kitchiness works
well and so when i say they're horrible
i'm just projecting my own aesthetic yes
sensibilities preferences desires yeah
but for i might actually see it in
someone else's house
it would look so out of place in my
house but i might see in someone else's
house say that's really cool that you
did that yeah and that you turned your
old president's club awards into coat
hangers or into i mean they had all
kinds of ideas in fact sean if you can
find that pinterest board put it in the
show notes please
but then let's get real practical here
right right since she said she has
awards plaques think about plaque for a
second
we go to the dentist to get rid of
plaque
is that what they're taking off
and yet in our homes we cling to the
plaque what a metaphor yeah but if
you're if you really want to let go of
these things because they're no longer
adding value to your life you can take
pictures of them obviously and uh that
way you still have the memory trigger in
your home but this is an article ryan
from recycle bank we'll put a link to
this in the show notes as well it's
called what can i do with old trophies
and metals
old trophies and metals are often made
from recyclable materials but they also
hold value in their current form and
many can be reused a number of companies
have programs dedicated specifically to
the art of refurbishing trophies the
best known of these include total awards
and promotions and there's a link in the
article to that place they're in madison
wisconsin and lamb awards and engraving
in westminster maryland these programs
break unwanted awards down for parts
like if you steal a car and then you're
like
you sell it for parts run the wrong
business
we can steal trophies that's right
actually i think you have to pay to for
them to do this but uh i think it's like
a dollar or something anyway let me let
me just go to the rest of the article
and then we can talk about it here
rebuilding new trophies and plaques with
whichever parts are usable and recycling
the rest so they recycle it for you so
you don't have to worry about it you
don't want to put in landfill they'll
reuse or recycle these for you the
rebuilt items are then donated to
non-profit organizations or resold both
programs will allow you to ship trophies
that are in sufficiently good condition
for nominal processing and shipping fees
please note their restrictions
while metals are accepted by these
groups there are also options dedicated
specifically to giving metals a new life
sports metal recycling there's a link in
here as well a massachusetts-based
organization contributes the proceeds
from recycling donated metals to
fundraising for charity runs the metals
are removed from their ribbons and
sorted for scrap recycling while the
ribbons are sent to cloth slash textile
recycling sports metal recycling even
makes sure that all the packing
materials you use to send them the goods
are recycled as well from bubble wrap to
cardboard boxes
so you get the point you can read the
rest of the article there but it shows
you that there are actually some places
the article goes on to say if you feel
bad about like shipping off your old
trophies or maybe you just can't afford
it then you can check with your local
there they're always going to be local
trophy shops around you within a certain
radius and yeah many of them accept
donations as well because they can reuse
your trophy sometimes it's just about
putting a new little name plate on the
trophy so if you don't want to ship it
off to one of these places in wisconsin
or maryland
you can obviously just go to your local
trophy shop and ask them also i do know
that goodwill will take a lot of
different trophies and awards as well so
you have options you don't have to cling
to them you don't have to throw them out
yeah yeah i love that idea that's that's
amazing mara i'd love to see you in a
few months ryan and i are going to be in
toronto we'll give you a couple tickets
to the love people use things tour stop
in toronto will also be in vancouver
both of those are in october the
minimalists.com
tour for tickets we're going to give a
live talk about minimalism a book
reading from our book love people use
things and we'll do a live version of
the minimalist podcast this week on the
maxwell episode ryan i want to talk to
you about some of your favorite moments
since we just finished the american leg
of the tour 18 cities down i realized
something that's our 10th tour in 12
years ironically this is actually our
longest tour because we had to postpone
some dates because of the weather and
travel restrictions and and covet et
cetera
but we had to postpone some things so
even though it's only a 20 city tour
it ended up being like 13 months long oh
my goodness was it really that long yeah
because we started in september of last
year in texas yeah yeah and then october
will be the end of the love people use
things tour but on on the maximum this
week i want to talk to you about some of
your favorite moments because
i'll tell you this we had
some of my favorite events we've ever
had yeah likewise chicago new york
yeah there's anyway we'll get into that
on denver was awesome oh my god denver
was like it was in a comedy club it felt
like a comedy show yeah it was good if
you missed any of those events you can
check them out on our patreon page
patreon.com
the minimalist we release one of those a
month once we get home and jordan and
podcast sean they they start to edit
those together make it look beautiful
for our lovely patrons also this week on
patreon i want to share something um
about
dumpsters about the dumpster method we
have a story from love people use things
that i read while we're on the road i'm
not going to share it publicly just yet
but we'll share it on the private
podcast ryan what time is it you know
what time it is it's time for the
lightning round where we answer your
text messages you can text your comments
your questions your smart remarks your
eggplant emojis you can send all those
to 937-202-4654
now those texts actually do go to both
of our phones we respond to as many
people as we can but we also answer some
questions here on the podcast they're in
the lightning round this is where ryan
and i do our best to answer these
questions with a short shareable less
than 140 character response we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like oh by the way if you're on if you
sent us a text you'd be you're entered
into our monday morning minimal maxims
we never send you spam or junk or
advertisements obviously but every
monday we start your week off with a
little bit of simplicity a monday
morning minimal maxim to start your week
out simply we have a question here today
from amy
i've been reselling items as a way to
pay down debt but now my kids are
getting attached and it's starting to
pile up how do i keep them from clinging
to my inventory
well ryan we talked about clean a bit
yeah and
i've got some
difficult truths for amy here there's a
reason they're clinging we talked about
the three reasons that someone might
cling to something maybe they don't feel
loved meaning they don't feel validated
or they don't have enough approval at
least that's their perception right yeah
the reason i clung to a lot of things as
a kid
was control i felt like i didn't have
control of the chaotic world around me
yes and so i held on to things that
weren't serving me anymore
or maybe they feel unsafe
for some reason and so instead of asking
how do i get my kids to let go or not
want these things ask them why
are they clinging to
this inventory yeah right because you
see it as inventory and it's easy to let
go of inventory right yeah because
letting go is not something you do it's
something you stop doing you stop
clinging to the excess but with your
kids it's not excess it's not inventory
it's precious to them well why is it
precious why do they claim because
they either feel unloved in some way and
so they're they're getting certainty
that way they're getting through
approval or maybe they feel like things
are out of control in their house or at
school
or in their neighborhood they feel
unsafe maybe
right and so what is underlying this
clinging as soon as you understand that
then you can set up the environment for
your kids so they don't feel the need to
cling yeah right now they feel like they
are not
enough
and if you feel
like you're not enough
then no external thing will ever make
you feel
complete
however if you've created an environment
where there's abundance there because we
claim only if we fail to realize
the abundance of our everyday lives
oh you could tweet that podcast sean
so
abundance is the default state
we unfortunately through our culture
through media through advertisers maybe
your kids are just watching a lot of
youtube ads and that's what's making
them feel incomplete that's what's
making them want to cling right
and the more we try
by the way the harder we fail
another tweet for you podcast john
that's something pithy um
because
as we try try try try try think about
this ryan you've uh
you've had trouble with sleep in the
past getting to sleep specifically yeah
and what happens when you are when
you're in that state and you try harder
to go to sleep you just
you just don't go to sleep even faster
thus the harder you try the harder you
fail right
and yet
when you stop trying when you're able to
just go to sleep there's no trying to go
to sleep i also think about your cat who
is a total scaredy cat yeah i remember
the first time i met your cat
i tried to pet him yeah and what
happened yeah he runs off yes the only
time i've ever pet your cat is when i
wasn't trying to pet your cat i set up
the environment where i felt he felt
secure yep he felt approved or loved
he felt like he was in control
and then he came over to me and allowed
me to pet him for about three seconds
right
but
if i would have tried i would have
continued to fail instead it was about
setting up that that state of abundance
that state of enough
and then letting things happen from
there yeah
totally agree man um
the thing i would tell mara is i'm sorry
amy the thing i would tell amy is this
kids do what we do
not what we say so amy
your kids and any kids out there the way
they are they're learning all that
behavior from somewhere
and this isn't a judgment this isn't uh
it's not a bad thing it's not a good
thing it's just an observation
and
for your kids
to cling the way that they are they're
learning that from somewhere and if it
was from you that's okay it's not a big
deal at all now you're starting to let
go and that's great
but
you know
even though it took you
overnight to just start letting things
go it's not going to happen that way
with your kids it's not going to happen
overnight
so the best thing you can do is really
lead by example and help them understand
the why
and then whatever they do from there is
you know that's that's on them
um
yeah it's it's okay if they're not
exactly how you want them to be
but you can certainly help them get
closer by understanding
and by setting an example that's great
because when you think about that yet it
seems like to to amy that it probably
happened overnight but maybe it took you
30 years to finally start letting go
right
you were breathing that air of clinging
so to speak for
30 years
how long have your kids been breathing
that same air that you were breathing
that you were displaying to them that
air that you were exhaling into the
environment of course
it was much more about what you've done
in front of them the things that you
were clinging to
now if they saw you clinging for their
entire lives let's say my daughter's
nine if she saw me clinging for her
entire nine years on this earth
then of course she's going to cling
because she sees that's what you're
supposed to do the example that's set
forth for me has been clinging up to
this point you're putting new air in the
room but it's hard for them to breathe
that air because they haven't been
exposed to it until now we'll get to our
right here right now segment in a moment
but first alabama you got something for
us here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hey there i am just listening to some of
your older podcasts and i came across
one where a caller was wondering about
letting go of baby clothes
one of the things that i've put in place
one of the rules that i've made for
myself is that in order for me to hold
on to things from my daughter's
childhood which i'm a person who is
nostalgic i like to hold on to things um
i still have the flower dress that my
grandma made for me when i was in my
aunt's wedding
and this rule kind of goes along with
that as well but i like to have a
picture a good picture of the item that
kind of gives a snapshot in time instead
of just having an item in a box
there needs to be a good picture to go
along with it to give it some context to
age the item
and just to give it a little bit more
meaning
so for example i've held on to just a
couple of my daughter's outfits from
when she was really little
and i have really good photos of her in
those outfits and i just feel like it
gives it a lot more meaning
than having a pile of clothes that
really have no relation to her
to actually have a photo to go along
with the cute little outfit
it just kind of sparks those memories a
little bit more
the same thing with her artwork when she
was little i saved all of her artwork
and it piles up after a while it's
really fun when they're really little
but as they get older you realize that
you have tons and tons of this artwork
and i started scanning things i would
date them and things so that i would
have an idea of when they came from but
once they pile up you really lose track
of
when they made those items how old they
were what school were they in and they
lose their
their real
sentimental value if they don't have a
story to go along with them
so
her daycare used to send pictures of
them making their artwork and so i've
held on to just a few pieces that i have
really good photos of her actually
making the item
um so that you know in the future her
and i can pull those out and look at the
picture and be like oh you know do you
remember this when you were making this
and look at the item at that time
and just keep a few things instead of
keeping everything and then i scan
everything else sooner or later i'll put
it together into a photo book or maybe i
won't but at least i have a scan of it
if i ever want to take a look back or if
she wants to look back and try and
remember some of the things that she
made
hi josh and ryan my name's alana from
rochester new york i'm just calling in
to share with the world that i've been
becoming more sustainable and trying to
use
less physical items things that are
wrapped in plastic things that are
store-bought or brand new
i found this really great website called
marley's monsters it's a small
family-run business that's in oregon and
you can order all sorts of awesome
sustainable goods from our website i
just ordered cloth paper towels that are
reusable
washable sponges some hair scrunchies
some reusable straws so there's some
really great items if people want to
check that out and be more eco-friendly
all right y'all for our right here right
now segment here's one thing that's
going on in the life of the minimalist i
forget to mention this so i just wanted
to mention it this time because we
create so much over on the private
podcast so basically every week every
tuesday we do the free version of the
podcast completely advertisement free
but that is supported by our patreon
supporters but that's not just a bonus
content club it's we do a private
podcast a long form podcast we let our
hair down we roll our sleeves up and
other mixed metaphors but it's really a
place where we um where we test out
things that we wouldn't necessarily talk
about in public if you sign up for uh
you can do it just month month to month
or if you sign up for a year you get
over one month for free
over there patreon.com
the minimalist so if you know you want
to support the show that's a great way
to do it in fact i got a thoughtful
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon supporters here inausha says i'm
so delighted to have joined the private
podcast i discovered the minimalist via
the trojan horse route i just wanted to
declutter now for those of you don't
know what she's saying here um ryan and
i will often say minimalism is a trojan
horse for us to talk about so many other
things
we uh we sneak in the door by talking
about decluttering or letting go of
material possessions but then when you
start dealing with that excess clutter
physically you start looking internally
maybe there's internal clutter mental
clutter spiritual clutter financial
clutter calendar clutter relationship
clutter we talk about all of these
things over on the private podcast she
says i listen to the free podcast to
inspire me during the tedious journey of
minimizing but the philosophy and the
insights from an uncluttered mind just
had me hooked i've had so much value and
inspiration that it was a no-brainer to
become a patreon subscriber and learn
even more i love how the private podcast
has completely changed the way i think
wow
that's beautiful you're welcome to join
us over there if you'd like every
thursday we put out a long form maximal
episode completely separate from our
minimal episode it tends to complement
the minimal but different questions
different podcasts different
conversations different articles we dive
deep for our added value segment this
week ryan
i am i've been listening
i've been uh trying to be more calm with
this move that we have going on we're
decluttering during our move as well as
a minimalist i don't barely own anything
but sometimes i feel like everything's
out of control
and so uh one way that i set an
environment
for understanding for healing for calm
is through music
and there's this album by
whatever the weather
and
the whole album every song title we're
gonna listen to
a little snippet here in fact you can
start playing it now podcast sean
this song is called 25 degrees celsius
every song has a different temperature
that's great and they're pr they're
probably trying to
um yeah to to mimic
what that temperature feels like to them
i thought about this when i was a when i
was a kid i thought it would be cool to
have a band called speed limit
and there would be different speed
limits oh that's great that was the
tempo of the song this is this is very
similar very similar yeah yeah i i
struggle doing the conversion so what
it's uh so celsius to fahrenheit is well
it's just it's 25 times 2 which is 50
and then you remove the zero which is 5
and then you add 32 which is 82 and then
that five you subtract it which would be
75 degrees
fahrenheit simple
yeah
the way i've always done is you took you
take
25 multiply it by nine fifths
and then you add 32. it's the same exact
thing it is the same thing yeah so it's
somewhere around seventy five or so
degrees anyway enjoy this from whatever
the wet weather
it's just calm music most of it's
instrumental not all of it there's some
vocals throughout the album the album is
also called whatever the weather
because
i feel like i want some calm music
sometimes to declutter because you can
declutter
no matter the weather weather and it's
77 degrees i just realized i did the
math wrong
oh by the way ryan we have a bunch more
surprise questions this week like i feel
stressed after letting go of too much
stuff at once how do you handle the
aftershocks of purging what a great
question the hardest thing for me is
parting with my children's baby things
why are baby blankets and favorite toys
so hard to let go of i am the repository
for dead people's things
i have items from my parents and both
sets of grandparents that hold so much
sentimental value to me but they also
clutter my home i want to let go
but where's the best place to start is
it
with my own stuff or is it with someone
else's stuff plus a million more
questions for the minimalist and if you
want to hear all that check out the
minimalist private podcast visit
patreon.com the minimalist to subscribe
and get your personal link so that our
weekly private podcast plays in your
favorite podcast app you also gain
immediate access to hundreds of hours of
private archives recordings of live
events exclusive home tours and our
private community of thousands of
open-minded minimizers like you
you can follow the minimalists on
tik-tok instagram facebook and twitter
at the minimalist if you want our
podcast show notes in your inbox just
sign up for our free email list over at
theminimalists.com on behalf of ryan
nicodemus podcast sean alabama jordan no
more social just danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and the rest of our team i'm joshua
fields milburn if you leave here today
with just one message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing that's just feeding
your greed oh i bet that you'll be fine
without it